la chronique de l'écho le jeudi et ce
soir une demi-heure d'économie au
programme apprentissage et sécurité des
commerçants avec comme chaque semaine la
liste des streams wilfried bonsoir à
tous alors on va parler d'abord de
l'apprentissage c'est un statut qui a
longtemps souffert d'une réputation de
votre garage si on peut dire mais qui
est de plus en plus prisée par les 16 25
ans d'un point de vue de l'économie du
pays il faudrait aussi augmenter ce
nombre d'apprentis pour notamment
assurer la reprise des entreprises dont
les chefs partir ou bientôt à la
retraite et le rapport gallois ce fameux
rapport sur la compétitivité préconise
d'ailleurs de doubler le nombre
d'apprentis en cinq ans dans le
département dans les yvelines on compte
42 cfa centre de formation des apprentis
qui forme environ 16 milles jeunes ce
sont des chiffres qui datent de 2009 mon
soir à notre invité
corinne wolf l'on soit vous êtes
directrice du cfa de versailles notre
cfa il ya soixante deux enseignants qui
forme environ 1500 apprentis dans des
filières très diverse un ça va
l'alimentation les soins personnels
l'alimentation l'hôtellerie la mécanique
vous à vous mes filles et garçons filles
et garçons avec des métiers masculins
comme la mécanique et la carrosserie et
des métiers féminins l'esthétique la
coiffure est ce que certaines filières
ont plus de succès que d'autres
alors quand on est jeune fille on a
forcément envie d'être coiffeuse ou
esthéticiennes ça c'est pas un cliché
s'était pas incliné je sais pas un
cliché elle arrive tout en disant je
coiffe ma poupée
depuis je suis tout petit non c'est
vraiment une vocation pour les jeunes
filles de la coiffure
et puis il y aussi des métiers qui
attire beaucoup nous sommes complets par
exemple est vraiment archi complet en
pâtisserie alors majorité de garçons
quelques filles aussi mais l'appétit
free est un métier qui attire c'est
certainement à la mode en plus en ce
moment avec les émissions qui se
multiplient autour de l'accusé avec la
pâtisserie tout à l'heure à lui se
disaient c'était une voie de garage
avant l'apprentissage c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui
non c'est plus le cas c'est en tout cas
ça l'a été sa souvent souffert d'une
image négative mais nous avons de plus
en plus de migrants de l'enseignement
supérieur qui se tourne vers
l'apprentissage des jeunes qui ont
entrepris des études universitaires qui
au moins un bac général une année ou
deux de facultés et qui reviennent vers
nous avec bien souvent un projet
professionnel
une motivation nous leur proposons une
formation en un an
pour le cmp alors que de manière
classique elle en deux ans et ce sont
des jeunes très motivés car selon la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles 85% des jeunes qui sont
passés par l'apprentissage trouvent un
emploi dès l'obtention du diplôme est ce
que c'est vrai oui ça fait mal hier
c'est vrai puisque nous sommes à 80 %
d'insertion professionnelle six mois
après l'obtention du diplôme
il explique pourquoi ce n'est plus une
voie de garage c'est une entrevue un
emploi rapidement vu le contexte
économique c'est forcément intéressant
possible et c'est le cas pour la plupart
lourde pour toutes les filières où
certaines filières je vais sont les
jeunes qui sont passés par
l'apprentissage on appris non seulement
d'une manière technique le métier mais
ils ont aussi appris à travailler nous
ont appris des savoir être qui étaient
nécessaires en entreprise alors vous le
disais le profil de ces apprentis peut
être assez varié puisque certains
viennent de l'enseignement supérieur et
puis d'autres sont tout jeunes c'est
c'est assez varié dans les classes sordo
3e souvent pouvoir attaquer ainsi
approchés nous nous sommes allés à la
rencontre de l'une d'entre elles
s'attaquent gladys mari elle est
apprentie chocolatière chez franck de
gosse c'est à montigny on regarde
ensemble ce reportage
132 contenu de mousse pour après
magliocco là dedans et par deux fois par
la dce marie a entamé il ya quelques
mois une formation de chocolatière à 18
ans elle a opté pour l'apprentissage ici
j'aurais pas l'école j'aurais
je vais tout le temps ici et j'ai coupé
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il ya des
avantages à l'école quand un week-end
mais de l'autre côté je préfère être ici
parce qu'on apprend plus de choses à
l'école elle apprend la fabrication de
ganache et praliné et comment faire des
glaçages et moulages technique qu'elle
peaufine ensuite à l'atelier passionné
par le travail du chocolat
la première fois que son métier m'a
donné envie c'est quand j'étais allé à
une journée portes ouvertes dans un cfa
et j'avais vu des pièces commercial en
chocolat et puis c'est côté artistique
qui m'attirait et bas par la suite
j'aime bien aussi c'est minutieux c'est
beau c'est bon aussi pour l'encadrer un
maître d'apprentissage qui doit avoir
acquis au moins 5 ans d'expérience et
bien évidemment le chef d'atelier qui
supervise son évolution est le travail
très très bien la peine au sein du
chocolat avec nous je pense qu'elle est
heureuse ouais ça se passe très bien et
plus en plus de filles c'est bien de
travailler avec les filles sont plus
minutieuse l'atelier de franck dubosc
compte quatre apprentis de en pâtisserie
et de en chocolaterie
un parcours que le chef a lui-même
emprunté à ses débuts de mon temps quand
on partait un apprentissage c'était
plutôt la voie de garage ceux qui
travaillent pas bien à l'école partie un
apprentissage est aujourd'hui moins
c'est quand même plus valorisé qu'avant
dans les yvelines 42 cfa forme plus de
16000 apprentis
un statut de plus en plus prisée par les
16 25 ans baladez vous l'avez suivi 1
c'est bien évidemment franck propose
qu'ils étaient interviewés dans ce
reportage
oui pour les amateurs de chocolat sachez
que ce samedi franck daubos donc ouvre
son atelier pour les gourmands au public
de 10h à 13h et de 14h à 17h c'est à
montigny c'est l'occasion de voir un
petit peu les coulisses de son travail
et puis vous pourrez aussi acheter
quelques chocolats présente pour noël
vous avez fait les cours que j'aurai
alors un apprenti va donc répartir son
temps envoyé dans le dans le sujet entre
les cours au cfa et puis le travail en
entreprise selon le diplôme choisi sait
quel est l'intérêt de ce système selon
vos de ne pas perdre pied avec
l'entreprise est de ne pas perdre pied
avec les cours non plus ça permet aux
jeunes justement d'aller de l'un à
l'autre d'avoir les apports théoriques
au cfa et puis de voir ce que ce qu'il
en fait en entreprise et puis l'avantagé
aussi pour les apprentis c'est qu'ils
ont un salaire ils ont un salaire bien
sûr qu'ils calculent et de quelle
manière
alors le salaire est calculé en fonction
de l'âge de l'apprenti et de son année
de formation
il commence mais excusez moi je veux
jouer il commence pour un jeune qui est
en première année qui a moins de 18 ans
à 25 % du smic et ça augmente chaque
année en fonction de son âge en fonction
de sa formation jusqu'à 70 75 % du smic
vous êtes la directrice de ce cfa depuis
quelques années est-ce que vous noté une
augmentation des demandes vous disiez
quand pâtisseries les demandes explosent
mais ce que généralement voilà il ya un
engouement pour l'apprentissage
il ya un engouement par l'homme pour
l'apprentissage il y à aussi d'un autre
côté un creux démographique et il ya des
métiers qui attire moins que d'autres
quand même alors la cuisine cette année
nous avons une carence d' apprenti en
cuisine et ceux ci seraient l'intérieur
mais pas la cuisine
voilà et ce n'est pas le rythme du
travail qui fait peur aussi peut-être à
5,12 mais c'est très difficile c'est
très difficile au niveau rythme et ce
n'est pas 2010
voilà on travaille le week-end faisait
c'est pas toujours facile quand on a 16
ans 17 ans quand on entre en
apprentissage de cesser ses activités
sociales les sorties avec les copains
samedi soir les choses comme ça aussi
qu'on
disait 85% un des jeunes diplômés
apprentis trouvent un emploi
c'est un véritable levier pour
l'insertion professionnelle oui et vous
savez l'année dernière pour la session
2012 tous métiers confondus nous avons
obtenu 84 % de réussite aux examens en
sachant que les jeunes entrent dans
notre établissement sans sélection au
niveau des résultats scolaires je trouve
que cette sont deux jolis résultats et
les enseignants sont dans la vie active
aussi ou alors il il se consacre
uniquement à l'horizon enseignants à
temps complet chez nous alors en début
de semaine la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat de versailles organisé une
conférence sur ce thème sont en
insertion professionnelle et
l'apprentissage que journaliste et
économiste bernard maryse faisait partie
des intervenants ont l'écoutent son
point de vue sur la question
je n'en de difficultés pour entrer ce
marché de travail avec le système des
stages
une espèce de bizutage entre guillemets
qui fait qu'ils n'ont pas accès au
marché du travail
c'est lié au contrat de travail qui
protège trop un certain nombre d'emplois
installés qui fait que les jeunes n'ont
pas accès à cela et de ce point de vue
l'apprentissage va être un moyen
essentiel de faire sauter le verrou qui
ferme la porte du marché du travail
il faut que tous les jeunes mais quel
que soit leur niveau de qualification
quel que soit leur niveau de
qualification puisse par l'apprentissage
avoir un prêt contact avec les
entreprises et à partir de là commence à
construire des emplois commencé à les
former à définir ces emplois est entré
dans les entreprises on a eu de bons
ministres l'apprentissage le palio
rénovant les deux bombes vise
l'apprentissage il s'est beaucoup
amélioré
on a fait des universités d'excellence
la notion de métier et va être désormais
reconnu beaucoup plus que ne l'était
autrefois elle va devenir aussi
important dans un pays comme la france
comme dans les pays comme l'autriche
comme l'allemagne comme la suède ou la
notion de métier est essentiel et ça va
permettre à tous ces jeunes de reprendre
un certain nombre d'entreprises qui vont
être en désirant sinon parce que la
pyramide des âges fait qu'il ya à peu
près 200 mille à trois mille artisans
qui vont partir et il faut trouver
justement des jeunes pour reprendre son
entreprise donc de ce côté là
l'apprentissage et l'artisanat bien
entendu un très bel avenir
une question de réputation paru plus que
deux cours d'une formation parce que la
formation et bornes franchement elle est
très très bonnes informations c'est
plutôt une question de marque comme vous
dites et de contenu de ce qu'on donne
une notion de métier métier on va tout
de suite quelque chose que finalement de
banal passé peut qualifier de bas de
gamme pas du tout il faut au contraire
que métier se devinent quelque chose de
très haut de gamme en france on joue
encore comme on le fait souvent en
france d'un petit peu chacun dans son
coin d'un côté les riches amis car le
côté y est les centres de formation
professionnelle de côte et à
l'université de l'autre côté il ya les
politiques bon tout ça est en train de
se recombiner une synergie va permettre
à mon sens ce concert devrait permettre
donner à la notion de métier tout son
sens corinne valls bernard maryse parlé
de l'importance de former ces apprentis
pour ensuite reprendre les entreprises
que les chefs d'entreprise laisseront
carillon à la retraite
est-ce que vos apprentis sont aussi
formés à la gestion monsieur rohmer ce
alors pas au niveau du sua p mais lorsqu
ils poursuivent leur formation soit par
un bp soit par un btm
ils ont des cours de gestion et ils sont
destinés à reprendre des entreprises
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur un
plateau merci pour votre éclairage et
puis une dernière information ainsi vous
êtes intéressés merci par
l'apprentissage sachez que le conseil
général a lancé au mois de septembre une
bourse aux apprentis vin d'un montant de
150 euros
l'enveloppé globale est de 200 mille
euros les conditions avoir entre 16 et
25 ans habitait dans les yvelines et
être non imposable
la date limite c'est en janvier 2013
plus d'informations sur le site qui
s'affiche à l'écran